life imitates art and art imitates life
but sometimes fiction and reality come a
little too close for comfort from
specific causes of death to predictions
of national tragedies no one intended
these episodes of TV to be so
haunting since news broke on October
28th 2023 of Matthew Perry's death
friends fans have been reeling over the
loss of The Man Behind the sarcastic and
lovable chandela Bing the many their
comfort show now has a dark cloud over
it especially since two episodes eily
foreshadow his death in season 9 episode
8 the one with Rachel's other sister
chandela suggests to Monica that they
use their expensive wedding plates for
Thanksgiving dinner she's hesitant but
obliges though the plates survived the
tense meal it's Chandler who
accidentally knocks over the entire box
of them shuttering the dishes on the
floor he tells his
friends
well what do you know I guess I'll be
the one who dies first while intended as
a gag this line takes on a whole new
meaning now as Perry is indeed the first
of the co six cast members to pass away
similarly in season 7 episode 5 the one
with the engagement picture Chandler
struggles to smile properly for a photo
to announce his and Monica's engagement
in the newspaper a frustrated Monica
says this a picture supposed to say
Geller and being to be married not Local
woman saves drowning authorities
initially believed Perry to have died in
a drowning incident though the exact
cause of his death is still being
investigated as of the making of this
video given the circumstances some fans
are calling for Monica's line to be CT
from the episode one of the most
heartbreaking Modern Family story lines
comes in season 11 episode 11 Legacy
when Tyber rals F dumy gross concerned
about his aging father Frank when he's
discovered seemingly lost in the grocery
store
Frank played by the legendary Fred
Willard assures his son that he's fine
and they spend an enjoyable day together
little just Phil know it's their final
day together and Frank passes away soon
after the episode aired on January 15th
2020 and exactly 4 months later Willard
died at the age of 86 just as Phil and
Frank spent the latter's last moments
reflecting on their relationship and
ending the day on a hopeful note Burell
and Willard did the same during their
last moment together on the Modern
Family set Frank knew his time was
coming to an end and Burell believes
Willard did too even while filming the
death of his Modern Family character
barell said in a tribute to Willard
published in Entertainment Weekly the
reason that moment was so poignant was
that he knew his time was limited and
the only real way for him to say goodbye
was to say I'll see you on the next one
that's the way he always thought he said
it with a wink and he knew that that
wasn't the case in 201 2015 the season 1
finale of Mr Robot was postponed from
airing on USA Network because one scene
is Darkly similar to a devastating
killing in Rowan o Virginia the week
before its original release date The
episode shows James plf Executive Vice
President of technology for ecorp
shooting himself on National Television
due to the irreversibility of the 59
hack just days before the Mr Robot
finale was due to air former WDBJ
reporter Vester Lee II shot and killed
two of his past colleagues reporter
Allison Parker 24 and cameraman Adam
Ward 27 while they were live on the air
covering the 50th anniversary of Smith
Mountain Lake sanan who also shot
himself was previously fired from
WDBJ for problematic Behavior he had
sued the station for discriminating
against him but his lawsuit was ruled as
baseless ABC News reported ultimately
the Mr Robot finale was postponed out of
sympathy and respect for the victim's
loved ones since the events that unfold
in it are disturbingly reminiscent of
the real life event throughout the Run
of Scrubs the hospital's unnamed janitor
makes the life of the lead JD as
difficult as possible he's always
pulling pranks annoying him and bending
the truth however one comment made by
janitor became eerily factual 4 years
after it was uttered on Scrubs in season
6 episode 7 AA veteran Brian dancer
comes a Sacred Heart suffering memory
loss due to a head injury as a result
the war becomes a major topic of
conversation among the staff at the end
of the episode janitor tells JD in my
opinion we should be looking for bin
Laden in Pakistan in May 2011 4 years
after the episode Ed and nearly a decade
after Al-Qaeda leader Osama Bin Laden
orchestrated the terrorist attack on New
York City's World Trade Center towers US
Navy Seals located him in Pakistan where
he was swiftly executed so maybe not
everything that came out of janitor's
mouth was a downright lie after all the
shortlived xfile spin-off The Lone
Gunman isn't all that well remembered
including its seeming prediction of the
terrorist attack that changed the United
States forever in its pilot episode
which aired on March 4th 2001 a hacker
hired by powerful government officials
takes control of a Boeing aircraft
intending to fly it into one of the
World Trade Center towers though the
lone gunman managed to stop the plane
and the Terri involved as a hacker
instead of hijackers the show's events
are incly similar in fact conspiracy
theories continue to Circle that the
real Attack was orchestrated by the US
government just like on the show despite
this unintentional prediction right down
to the brand of the plane not many
people made the connection between the
episode and the September 11th 2001
attacks the lone Gman executive producer
Frank spotnet told the Daily Star I woke
up on September 11th and saw it on TV
and the first thing I thought of was the
lone gunman but then in the weeks and
months that followed almost no one
noticed the
connection despite running for only 21
episodes between 1987 and 1988 second
chance later titled boys will be boys
makes an early spot- on prediction about
the eventual death of the Libyan
dictator Colonel moama Gaddafi set in
the then futuristic year of 2011 St
Peter greets newly deceased souls and
has them take a test to determine if
they'll be spending eternity in heaven
or hell in one episode Gaddafi appears
Before Peter in disbelief that he's dead
when asked to step onto a machine to
decide his fate it lights up red Peter
tells him because you have ordered the
death of innocent people by means of
terrorist explosives you are sentenced
to spend eternity wired as a human bomb
Peter's comment likely refers to the
April 5th 1986 bombing of a West Berlin
dance hall where two were killed and
over 200 were injured as predicted in
Second Chance Gaddafi died in 2011 aided
by the US Britain and France he was
killed at the hands of his own people
who had enough of his lengthy regime in
June 2005 a mere month before four
terrorists bombed the London Underground
under bus the cast of Spooks a British
drama about security intelligence agents
working to prevent threats shot an
episode that involved an attempted
bombing on the city's Transportation
Network though the fictional agent
stopped the attack this wasn't the case
in the real life July 7th event which
killed 52 and injured over
770 spook star Peter F told the
independent at one point the episode
wasn't going to be shown because it was
too near the mark in the end the episode
went out in a very heavily edited
version the amended episode eventually
aired in September 2005 just a few
months after the real bombing the show's
ability to predict the future wasn't
limited to this instance with another
example including Russian tensions with
the UK Richard Armitage who played Agent
Lucas North was a little freaked out
over the show's preemptive plot lines
commenting are the Spooks team writing
the newspapers as well Legends of
chamberlane heights was a Comedy Central
cartoon that followed three aspiring
Young basketball players running from
2016 to 2017 in one episode the trio of
Grover Malik and Jamal encounter the
legendary Kobe Bryant after a helicopter
crash he's on the ground being crushed
by the chopper or clutching his trophies
and asking the boys to help him before
they Cana the helicopter explodes in
January 2020 Bryant died tragically in a
helicopter crash along with his
13-year-old daughter Giana overcome by
thick fog the pilot was said to have
lost his sense of spatial awareness this
caused him to unintentionally fly
downward and crash into a hillside where
the helicopter exploded into flames none
of the nine IND individuals on board
survived the
incident Captain James T Kirk and
science officer Mr Spar are rather
stressed in Star Trek season 2 episode
26 assignment Earth because Interstellar
agent Gary 7 threatens to wreak havoc on
the events of the 20th century a
particularly Eerie moment comes when
Spar talks about an
assassination current Earth Crisis would
fill a tape Bank Captain there will be
an important assassination today this
episode aired on March 29th 1968 and
only a few days later on April 4th civil
rights activist Martin Luther King Jr
was shot and killed on his balcony at
the Lorraine Motel in Memphis Tennessee
King was actually a massive fan of Star
Trek and he was the one who encouraged
actress Nichelle Nichols one of the
first black women to play such a
powerful character on screen to stay on
the show as Lieutenant Ur after she
contemplated leaving TV for Broadway
Nichol said in a Reddit Ama thread that
King told her if you leave they can
replace you with a blond-haired white
girl and it will be like you were never
there what you've accomplished for all
of us will only be real if you stay on
November 7th 2001 less than 2 months
after the attack on the Twin Towers in
New York South Park crators Trey Parker
and madstone did what they do best
concoct an over-the-top episode about a
headline in season 5 episode 9 the boys
travel to Afghanistan to return a goat
sent to them by four Afghan children as
reciprocation for the $1 their teacher
forced them to donate while there
Cartman and friends are taken hostage by
Bin Laden and the Taliban after a Looney
Tunes segment between Cartman and the
militant Bin Laden finds himself darning
an Uncle Sam Ensemble not knowing who he
is Bin Laden's followers fire at him
causing the explosive in his hands to
detonate a US Navy SEAL then delivers
one more shot to Bin Laden's head to put
it lightly this is not how things went
down in real life still Parker and stone
got a few things right he was was
secretly living in plain view of
everyone though in Pakistan not
Afghanistan and of course he was shot
and killed by a seal in season 10
episode 22 of Family Guy several Tales
are told including one where Peter
Griffin gains the ability to turn
everyone in COG into Robin Williams
though it's fun at First Peter soon
becomes agitated about being surrounded
by endless versions of the actor even
tries to kill himself to escape them the
episode originally aired in May 2012 but
reruns were shown for years after after
on August 12th 2014 the episode finished
airing on BBC 3 in the UK just as the
news broke of Williams death by Suicide
a BBC spokesperson told the independent
this was a repeat that we have shown a
couple of times before so who could have
planned that it was scheduled more than
2 weeks ago it is just an uncanny
coincidence another Family Guy episode
came extremely close to predicting the
death of US Supreme Court Justice anonin
Scalia in season 5 episode 8 Peter calls
on death to send him back in time so
that he can stop his 18-year-old self
from cancelling a date with his now wife
Lois however Peter accidentally changes
the past and Lois ends up with Glenn
Quagmire when Peter asks death to send
him back so he can make things right
death Recs Dick Cheney the chairman of
Halle Burton shot Supreme Court Justice
Scalia in a hunting accident and a
bullet went right through him and killed
Carl Ro and Tucker Carlson while that
exact outlandish situation did not
happen Scalia did die while on a hunting
getaway in Texas on February 13th 2016
about a decade after the 2007 Family Guy
episode Ed Scalia was found dead by
Ranch owner John Poindexter after the
associate Justice didn't attend
breakfast if you or someone you know is
struggling or in crisis help is
available call or text 988 or chat 988
lifeline.org
[Music]